[Music]
so you know who [ __ ] mack is you
probably do
you know [ __ ] mack is merch
a rapper obviously okay
i don't know this one probably one of
the stupidest people i've ever seen
he doesn't remember what what the word
french fries is
this is real by the way this is not a
skit okay here you go
[Music]
yeah this is an order you order it now
come on let's get this up
get it out this way like a county jail
fade
let's get uh the fire shrimp
the dinner yeah the shrimp fried shrimp
like with that right there
these are the coconut shrimp do you want
the appetizer no like fried like not not
like normal but like
no just the shrimp cover some some
potatoes some five fives tell her oh
yeah and put some ground up glass in it
because that's how i like to eat that
too
yeah like walks a walk dinner fried
shrimp with two sides but the potatoes
things you get from mcdonald's
he doesn't remember what the word french
fries is
he doesn't remember what the word french
fries is i was thinking maybe he didn't
know like what hash browns were not like
nah you know the things you get with the
big mac and mcdonald's we don't like the
potatoes like you know potato you cut
them in a strip put them in a deep fryer
what they call them
yeah
french fries oh is that what they're
called
okay i love this man is that what they
called
is that what they called rolling in the
chat said this guy ate a fireplace yeah
no tell her what i'm talking about okay
you want the coconut right no i want the
normal shrimps
what you had with the hamburgers you
said the word yeah
what what french
fries it's it's like even when she said
it he's like i don't
i didn't register that whatever you said
hey what are the squished up potatoes
you get at kfc they're like squished
they're squishy
mashed potatoes nah nah nah and they
squished and they put like this brown
juice on them
that's gravy yeah nice mashed potatoes
yeah give me the smushed potatoes and
and then and brown drink in the brown
drink
who is this guy
don't worry we have we have a deep dive
i got more onions oh my god i need more
of this guy in my life
he's the best hey yo yo yo hey uh let me
get a sausage on what are them round
bread things they're round they bread
honestly i normally would be so annoyed
with somebody that's stupid but there's
something just delightful about him he's
so delightfully stupid
and give me one of them uh
that clear liquid that clear liquid
that's in the ocean what's that called
nah what's that black drink y'all got
with the fish the fizzy black drink
coca-cola
whatever i know i know man like they
they just got the fuzz in it and it's
like black yeah bring me that one of
them okay so let me get this straight
let me get this straight you want the
scrimp
with um
the regular scrimp yeah no no no no no
no yeah the regular the regular scrims
okay so you want the regular scrimp with
the side of the things they give you at
mcdonald's
yeah the potato things yeah yeah yeah
and and the
and what's some of that like i want to
be able to dip them in something you got
that what's that red stuff look like
blood but it like thicker ketchup
yeah something like that i don't know
okay so you tell them what i'm talking
about
you tell them tell them what i want
the thing on the side so you want that
with and i quote
the dark drink with the fuzz in it
uh-huh okay all right
no problem sir we'll be right up with
that
i want to see this guy order dessert oh
[ __ ]
french fries
that's my fries okay
i want waffle fries yeah yeah one more
brown what is he is he afraid to say
fries
oh and uh let me get one of them uh
little soft brown square things with the
scoop of that stuff on top the cold
stuff that's on the warm stuff
brownie all the mode i don't know man
just bring me some of that
can i try first so i know it's the right
thing
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
who is this man i love him rapper one
more side
what other side you got right here
whatever side you got
what's his name though i gotta look this
guy up oh no no don't don't don't don't
don't spoil it
i i'm gonna do trust me i'm gonna do the
whole thing for you i'm doing the whole
thing for you
right after this video's almost over
anyway let's do a let's do crackling you
know coach warren does he wants rock he
wants crock lee
you want you want some croco
that sounds like drug like slang right
yes
man i got that far ass crock lee well
there's a little mini documentary on him
the channel five people did it you know
the all gas no breaks
here you go
oh that's cold old english right here
okay i'm watching these streets also
when these weird ass [ __ ] in these
cores [ __ ] this [ __ ] ain't a game i
like to let [ __ ] know around
the world to get real tricky to get real
mickey you're real dangerous my goddamn
he can't affect your fist trying to do
it god great man on hood but i'll [ __ ]
your wife custer
i'm gonna keep it fifty-fifth straight
who's custer
what did he say does anybody know what
he said
what does it mean to be a nifty you tell
a sitch you want to bust her [ __ ] an
[ __ ] open you fight me and then you
have a nifty issue with her care if i be
gonna do nifty thanks in that moment is
he playing music from oblivion yes and
then skyrim he's great playing oblivion
music that's amazing [ __ ] let's go
ahead and keep it 55th street this 55th
street how long have you been hanging
out here for oh cuz i got put on cut i
was a teenager what does it mean to get
uh put on okay well i can take you an
alley one of y'all want to catch this
friendly fave with crepe mac nick wants
to get put on come on kirk come on now
nick
nick nick wants to get put on i don't
think [ __ ] funniest part of that
video
is he like they're frozen asian we just
go to l.a we go to the hood yeah we go
put him on he won't see uh get uh frozen
frozen wants to get put on actually
specifically earlier he was talking
about getting put on so yeah he'll do it
custer [ __ ] come on
i fight anybody i don't give a [ __ ]
how do you feel i'm a little nervous
i've never been put on oh god i've never
been put on back go nick
[ __ ] video man to come in the
[ __ ] 55th street and actually
attempt a 55th street fake i got more
heart than all these other custer ass
[ __ ] video people out here oh i
know what he's doing
bloods
crips
he's changing the bee
to custer custer buster buster
[ __ ]
oh you're right instead of buster
because that's a b see i've seen that in
written form i've never actually seen
that in speaking for yeah
okay hold on a second though but that
doesn't explain why we couldn't say
french fries because that doesn't even
have a b i don't know what the french
fries thing is i'm thinking maybe you
wouldn't say fries because there'd be in
it but it doesn't well crock lee
oh that's why didn't say broccoli that's
why you said croco that explains the
crock lee okay okay
never made the cut i'm gonna keep it
55th street but if you would have stayed
back here and more mothers would have
came you kept on fighting as long as you
get up and keep fighting
on hood i love him
oh he's everything with a scene all
right okay you're the eventually got put
on we're gonna name him dynamite blue
dynamite blue i like wouldn't it be
dynamite clue
you don't want to no it's
oh god you're right it should be
dynamite clue
can they they can still probably say
blue because it's their color maybe yeah
maybe you're right the only bee they can
use that's only b
but he's not a blood he's a [ __ ] his
name is [ __ ] mack
yes no but they're crippled but they're
they
are blue
bloods are right that's a red oh you're
right okay sorry so if you can't use
bees why did you pick the color it
starts with b because reds were taken by
the bloods and the asians
you know there's seven primary colors
purple purple and you know what i'd be
i'd be magenta
remember if you ever do a lot of time in
jail never commit suicide
all right hey
yeah this is a great public service
announcement this guy is better than
anything biden said
hey listen man listen cuz when you in
jail whatever and you got thoughts of
suicide reach out to somebody mm-hmm
you're like wow what a wholesome moment
big [ __ ] thing of water out that
[ __ ] back of that car lupe from 406
neighborhood crips so she's from the
photies right up the street
oh lupe's a great woman she's an
assistant she helps me with a lot of
things out here how long have you guys
been together for we're not in a
relationship really no
that's my driver i had no idea i thought
you guys were in a relationship bro
i'm his homegirl bro you know it's a
difference between citrus and homegirls
you know i don't gotta you know wear his
whistle or nothing like that you fight
me she's gonna keep her gripping her
wear his whistle
wet his whistle suck his dick wet his
whistle i thought he'd wear his wife
okay gang bang is solid and she thinks
no she isn't they gonna respect her like
we respect lupe you fight me he's the
prettiest girl you ever uh
uh you know did the thing with
yeah that's pretty
well that's that's hard oh yeah that's a
hard question y'all ah we gonna answer
this okay let's get you took let's do uh
shaniqua shaniqua she is uh the top
and uh keep it 50 fair straight you
fight me we'll do stacey mack what do
you want to be when you get like like
what's your what's your life goal well i
told you i want to own the stuff i have
the kids the gems and [ __ ] some big
booty beautiful stitches they could run
beautiful
beautiful the program get backfired the
community as i find c5c5 but over money
i ain't never gonna change i am snoo the
[ __ ] i am i'm gonna keep it 55th street
you want to see one of his songs
yeah but more than more than breathing
okay well i think you're gonna be
surprised because
a lot
i don't think i'm not saying this is a
joke i don't think it's that bad but you
tell me we're gonna keep it 55th street
oh hood we're gonna keep it 50 fish
straight
and that's six she need an issue oh what
we hit her with
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
all these [ __ ] hate and if you want
beef i'ma put it on the plate i don't
want no pork meat you [ __ ] is the
jenks it's real stainless better go home
you piss me off make a card and it's off
with your legs
[Music]
that's the wiggle on the stitch counting
big chips you'll see it show my case you
want the crisp flip i'm a tiny low play
ball stay
western blue rag all blue clothes
stacking my money up bubble up [ __ ]
rich roll got to get it out the mud came
from nothing real 55th street low came
from thugging i feel like you're still
kind of hanging around nothing though
yeah i know he is
he's in front of a 7-eleven
out of control a nickel explode we're
from county jail phase and domino's you
fight me i'm about the green lil cinch
can you see juicy
yeah
i don't like this or anything but it's
not the worst thing i've heard what was
that other one you showed me oh i like
the one where he was by himself that one
wasn't bad i'll say this he's no snooty
wild
but
it was this one right there
[Music]
[ __ ] not popping
little knockers
more
sorry mythical vigilante we have a new
official rotc musician
more yeah sorry mythical vigilante
you're fired watch he sends us an email
later going no i understand that guy's
really good that's really good
can you guys actually can you get me in
touch with him because i might be able
to i'd love to work with him
now tomorrow there'll be a passive
aggressive remix of one of the [ __ ] mag
songs by him
the mythical vigilante is gonna send him
an email like with a resume and like
some samples of his work and then a
picture of him like
like living his idyllic life with his
huskies
okay bro i think we have a lot in common
you and me yeah no bees in your words
when you're messing oh yeah no bees
you're not allowed to the b birds
[Music]
oh you get it
you get it that's [ __ ] mack
hope you've all been enlightened